l'année du bac c'est l'année la plus
l'année ferme ta gueule c'est la
dernière fois que tu m'interromes tu as
compris sinon je viens chez toi je
séduis ta mère et je t'ai fais des
petits
frères ça fait 60 ans que le lycée
s'affronte dans une olympiade nous
sommes la risée de tout le
monde mais pourquoi on na'appelle pas
les se
pas c'est les sec pas dont on parle qui
conduit on
va il a pas champion de ski qui
vient ce que je veux dire fait en sorte
qu'il soit là d demain c'est vraiment SK
je je vais passer ma prière
[Musique]
étoile donc tu sais pas ce qu'
est la piste no Mo j pas c'est trop j
vais les gars s tu veux aller
desessous il do
réaler
est le ptinage cette flamme moi je peux
t'aider allez Michel suis-moi par contre
Michel le mieux on t' déjà dit que tu la
même
queta en chaleur tu es encore TR Brou
non tu dors pas ici comment ça je dors
pas ici une femme il est multiple c'est
ta mère c'est ta S c'est ta meilleure
amie pourquoi tu crois que je suis
encore avec je sais pas pour les papiers
c'est pas
ça les plus grand de ce monde sont des
zuerberg et billes de gros pour vous
dire que moi aussi je suis un sec
pas ser le numéro 10 formidable les
copains on est foutu mais c'est bon
monsieur je sens même plus mes pieds ah
mais nous on les sent frérot on les sent
très
bien